he's one of our favorites he's Frank
Caliendo the comedian actor
impressionist and Frank on stage calm
learn more about Frank upcoming live
performances he'll be in Connecticut
Boston Wisconsin outside of Madison and
joins us here I always feel like when
I'm reading something or delivering
something that you're studying me to try
to imitate me there is a little bit of
that you know who did that I was I was
like we're talking off the air a little
bit partially off the air about
Letterman and Stephen Wright the
comedian he was he's like oh no you
doing it right now
it's just he looked at me like that and
start like I was I don't even know I was
but I was studying like there's certain
things about you and this isn't this
isn't something we planned or anything
like that but I just you you're very
upper-body oriented yeah I don't know if
you've had an issue that's there's this
and you don't always turn you you so I
see that yes you should have brought it
up don't bring up a physical ailment
possibility but you can't do my voice
you can just do mine elements yeah well
I've worked on the voice before and
tried to get it and I couldn't get it
there was there was a time and if you
remember this it was a while back I
think in New York that you do this
sometimes you don't say dan Patrick
again dan Petry it's there's a it's a
it's almost like its own word I'm Dan
Patrick I'm Dan Patrick you know it's
it's something like that that happened
something that was I was trying to latch
on to but I never got anywhere but she I
have a Midwest accent and I don't know
if that's harder to imitate well I'm
from I grew up in Wisconsin but don't
you imitate have distinct yeah well
Berkeley like for example Charles
Barkley has all kinds of stuff he's from
the South Philadelphia he is out in
Phoenix so there's a mixture of a lot of
different thing going on there somebody
like Gruden I don't know what is grown
man but Gruden's from the Midwest yeah
right is he went today yeah I tell you
that story before when I met him he's
like I'm like when I first met him
everybody wanted to see was this gonna
go well so if I could do it again right
so you're at the mothership and you meet
the in schleier this' sitting there with
a cup of coffee gonna so ah
Gruden's like so you're the guy who does
me huh he's like where are you from i
looked up where he was from amicus and
he's like really I'm like no he's like
good cuz you were blowing my mind the
great thing is now that I become kind of
I think we're friends I don't know if
he's mocking me or what but I he'll get
text from him at like 5:30 in the
morning oh he's a really early morning
rise 5:30 like lunchtime hours videotape
man you're not gonna believe what Jay
Gruden's doing Paulie does shut could
you judge paulie's Gruden yeah hey that
guy's just playing football
it sounds like Paulie yeah doing it to
you right but I don't have any of the
mannerisms yeah you got the face cheats
it a lot if you can do something with
the face and look in the eyes that helps
then you do there are plenty of people
that do better all-out impressions than
I do I've met some people recently this
guy P at Michael Ross Marquand among
other people Ross Marquand is on The
Walking Dead
he's does some of the most amazing like
impressions I've ever heard what I've
done is I've kind of gotten bored with
that and these people are better than me
I think to start with anyways but I got
I got bored with it and started turning
everybody into characters that was when
it became more fun to me the Dana Carvey
school of impressions because doing the
dead-on impression you go on YouTube
they're so many great impressions now
incredible but they just do lines from
young VCS and it's there's nothing to go
with it if you watch a Carvey thing
Carvey would come up with a full on
character that you didn't even care phil
heartman the same way Phil Hartman
sounded kind of like people what you
wanted the person he was doing the
oppression of to be more like Phil
Harvey I mean he wanted him to be that
guy
so people do make that mistake of hey
listen to me I'm gonna recite a movie
line yeah it's it's great and sometimes
you're amazed for a quick second and
then you're bored afterward so it's like
that's what I tried to find that's why
Madden became the
it wasn't even saying words weren't fun
anymore yeah making weird and which I
think didn't thrill him but no no I
wouldn't but it was that becoming of
that kind of character and grooves
become rune for me is more fun not
talking the awkward silence of just a
look we still on TV right you can tell I
asked him what time I go why why are you
why do you look so mad this is he was
with Tirico at the time like why do you
look so amazing I want to talk football
man TV but he's gotten he's gotten I
talked to him about this - I said you've
gotten really good in your commercials
Gruden is he used to that first Hooters
commercials like go doters fries i was
like he was like so just nothing there
and now he's got a bunch of commercials
he's like rude not like I'm like there's
a there's a fun character to him and
he's being he's having fun with that
he's Jon Gruden and that's the key and
he's not to the point this was another
thing that he probably didn't care but I
was yes he's spouting it out because I
believed it to be true I said you're not
over-the-top being yourself you're just
being yourself and that's enough don't
try and be the caricature of you yet
that's further along probably you know a
few years down the line just keep being
that guy that is you fixing a tire and
that's funny enough you don't need to go
over the top but you provide the
caricature I do cuz that becomes more
fun for me which is probably he did text
me goes I just did a commercial where I
did impersonation I didn't ask him which
I did I was too scared to ask him I
don't know if he's doing me puts a
pillow in his belly or something I am
Jon Gruden a little chubbier version huh
feels like chris farley doing it wasn't
a okey-dokey
no that very topical impressions today I
was watching the John C McKinley thing
thinking I could do not you bunk G by
the way I got the greatest acting lesson
in the world from John C McKinley do you
have to say the C I don't even know felt
like that there must be a John McKinley
and oh my god is he awesome it was
incredible he's just telling me
things I'm thinking gosh I kind of do a
little bit of that but that's why you're
so good plays wait what was the lesson I
don't want to give it out that's free
that maybe after the break see crystal
didn't you see crest no I don't you
don't care - I don't think I could pull
it off are you only interested in the
people you're interested in as opposed
to somebody who's Tom what was that John
Madden I you know what I've actually
lost a lot of thee I've been working on
the acting side of stuff and that's why
watching somebody like him it was so
amazing to me and watching him and move
because I watched people and I go there
so in the character that they're not
there themselves anymore but then you
see and I talking to him I see the
little piece of him that's in there and
that's the thing that I've learned about
acting and the thing that I've tried to
put in the impressions but as far as the
passion for the impressions I've kind of
lost it because I feel like where am I
going to go with the next thing and
maybe it's just a part of getting older
or something like that but I'm at this
feeling where I I want to just I
pigeon-holed myself so much in that way
and that don't wait you're getting deep
here yeah I mean that's but that's where
it is and I think I'm just in such a
weird place but are you in a crossroads
here yeah totally seriously yeah totally
because I've always been the business
part of show business I'm worried about
how can I make more money doing this how
can i what what will get me more Twitter
followers when I was on Twitter Blais I
was just going I was just saying mean
thing and I was gaining a thousand
followers in a week and stuff like then
I realized I'm just doing this all the
time that's all I do now is I just try
to look for angry things to say and then
I'm doing it in real life so I'm walking
down summer and I want to say something
I'm going I'm just gonna tweet it you
vocally this is awful this is a terrible
so I got off it and got away from me but
why are you angry I'm not that was the
thing I wasn't angry it was just because
I because you would say these things you
tweet them out immediately it would just
get rid of that interaction between
other people and look that's one thing
you learn about in acting is like
listening to the other person right and
paying attention and actively listening
and not just
uh-oh when you do a scene you go off and
it's if when the other person is talking
it's so tempting to just be thinking
what's my next line I got to make sure I
get then you're not in it at all but if
you're actually there with them and
you're you're thinking the whole time
and he was talking about the word verbs
what are you doing that was really they
acting less and it that on the broad
strokes it won't mean as much but it
really is what are you doing the whole
time and it's not just I'm trying to get
you to do this that's that's the weak
way out it's what are you doing and it
was just just the way he kept doing that
with the eyes it was almost rudeness I
was like I'll tell you what man do you
want to retire I like to do I mean
retire these impersonations
no because people I still think enough
people like you know they do it's fun
out for the Madden out there once in a
while they wear it and I've heard I
heard you talk about this the other day
too
it's maybe it was earlier earlier today
as well I don't know I'm I'm one of
those people who goes out there and
tries to hit a lot of different
audiences I think people like Bill Maher
brilliant but very polarizing in terms
of the kind I watch them a go that's an
unbelievably quick line how did you come
up with that fast and you definitely
have a point of view on it for me it
doesn't work that way cuz people I got
as many people for the left as the right
that are in my audience I don't want to
take aside I just don't I don't and
that's not even really me I like to
listen to what everybody has to say and
have the conversation but I don't know
what's okay anymore
I'm totally flustered that's what that's
part of why I try to get out of comedy a
little bit more but you can stay in your
world it's when if you if you did a
Donald Trump and personation if you did
that's not polarizing at all yeah of
course no it's you know and ice but I
try to think okay so it's not even the
impression cuz my impression is silly
right my impression is say but then
people will say oh you're not being mean
enough with it you've got to resist and
all and I'll get calls from friends in
entertainment ago you got to go after
I'm like but that's not me and you'll
make your own decision on that it's like
I thought about that I get worried about
all the time about what I'm gonna get
myself in trouble with this is one of
those times so wait are you gonna get in
trouble right now possible okay let me
take a breath to the break
we're gonna take a break the trouble
after the break Frank's career is gonna
come to a crashing halt here and
probably get a tweet from the president
find out what he does says next here on
the Dan Patrick show Frank Caliendo
joining us and you tuned in at the right
time because his career may come to a
crashing end here it's happened a couple
times already
Frank on stage calm to learn more about
his upcoming tour stops he'll be in
Wisconsin Boston and Connecticut so
where did we leave off Frank
what was that tease well I was talking
about is just about president Troy
because I don't know where to go with
the Trump stuff nowadays because I get I
get it from all angles I'm always been
silly Alec Baldwin just won a aming an
Emmy with and his is a very mean version
and I watched at the beginning I was
like gosh I don't know I could never be
that but that's what people I think
that's part of the Twitter well like
when somebody out there like Trump he
goes and he's always kind of trolling
people kind of he is whether I don't
care where you're on the political
spectrum that's just what he does right
but I thought this is terrible this is
really bad but all we really had to do
with this national anthem stuff and I
want to say this that I understand all
these different sides I get it see how
much I'm capitulated yeah but I come on
Frankie to the point but uh but all he
really had to say is I want everybody to
take a knee during the national anthem
or [ __ ] that and then everybody's gonna
be standing right immediately
everybody's gonna be doing the opposite
of Trump and he but then he wins either
with the buddy if he to come with that
troll everybody should sit that's what I
want I want sitting kneeling and then
you'd be like oh no what do we do now
but do people okay so you get the left
that wants you to pile on or yeah I
think so and then I don't know I don't
even know exactly who's I talked about
this with my friend we do a podcast
sometimes together John homework and we
talk about this constantly I don't think
anybody voted for Donald Trump to think
that he was going to be this suave quote
they were again looking for more change
whether they got the change they were
looking for or not is your own decision
but it was that weird it was that that
thing where people looking for change
but he do when he's out there it's
always something I just want to go just
just stop for a little bit relax it's
all gonna be it would be easier but it
feels like the the
people made a name for themselves
impersonating a president yeah that's a
little bit so you're you there's so many
people doing Trump right now and the
internet gives you so many different
ways to do it when george w bush who was
very simple to do i think as well when
he there the internet wasn't what it is
now there would have been thousands of
people but it was really will ferrell
first with the college kind of guy the
the you know he was always confuse boy
yeah i guess we're gonna go out there
get him you know and that i took him is
like a little kid you know just confused
just trying to get there so they were
there are different versions but it's
the same guy and you see different you
have some Gruden and no that's a little
man here they all start to become the
same guy after a while a what man my
fellow Americans did you ever meet the
president bush did you mean no I was
supposed to do I did an event Dick
Cheney sitting right next to me and we
yeah mate was right after he shot the
guy did you do the bush impersonation to
Dick Cheney yeah I did it right there
was a Congressional Correspondents
Dinner oh I was doing I was doing the
whole thing I think it was funny
I couldn't tell it was hard I didn't
knows I don't know if they if they think
it's funny or if they're allowed to
think it's funny yeah a lot of times
people are careful that's another thing
you're doing those events people don't
know if they're supposed to laugh or if
it's okay like you're doing I do a lot
of corporate shows yeah everybody looks
to the boss to see if he's like in here
like in here this is that okay to laugh
so they don't know and then they they
look around and like okay so that's
politics right there so you're at doing
like an event similar to that the
Congressional Correspondents Dinner
somebody does a harsh joke you think
it's funny you get caught laughing all
of a sudden it's on TV used in a
commercial against you know it's
impossible you get cameras or Bradshaw
said that to me once Terry Bradshaw a
good friend of mine
Terry busy not like you oh no he's fine
yeah just didn't like when you made I
see him at least once a decade and so
Frank Kelly didn't do he's like cameras
everywhere Frank cameras everywhere I'm
recording you right now what have you
heard paulie's Andrew Luck yeah a little
bit yeah okay
uh-huh grade the Stanford Cardinal it's
funny it's not really dead on
I know it's why I can't do the face I
could just do that ha yeah I always say
it looks like a cartoon version of
Wolverine scary but also a stuffed
animal at the same time big fan of comic
books my whole life but he's very close
to Madden that's the problem
is he talks and Heath match up perfectly
so it's it's that difficult thing in it
for me it always turns into mad that was
the same problem I had with Bill Walton
I first started Bill Walton the Madden
is here and then Bo Walters I remember
how great is that the existentialism it
could be a way you look but I've you
ever tried to do LeBron know any younger
guys are always harder to do
I think cuz they're not characters yet
the the athletes become when they become
when they get into like color analysis
and stuff like that then you hear that's
the easy thing for me okay so you get
you hear you hear something different
you know
Pacino at you know 25 is different than
Pacino now voice is so high and now it's
that you know wow he suddenly became
southern right I have no idea how we
even got here so it's those it's it did
DeNiro change at all a little bit yeah
gluten De Niro
yeah and George W yeah yeah everybody
becomes that you see that part of there
was the part of the thing I was talking
about with
Jhansi McGinley there was that you you
have to get that intensity and you you
find that part and what you're what
they're doing and DeNiro I think is
pushing you in a lot of ways he's just
become that character he's always doing
that no I'm gonna get somewhere we're
gonna make this go longer
how about Jerry Jones he has it was like
he's he could be in your wheel and
there's the I do kind of cartoony
version he is the master manipulator in
an interview like you'll start the
interview and it's like what's wrong
with the Cowboys if there's a blade that
we will have a right now Jason Garrett
if you ask me today is our head coaching
if you ask me tomorrow I will tell you
today the Jason Garrett was our head
coach and by the end you're going I'm
sorry mr. Joe I didn't mean to interrupt
you and you see it in every interview
somehow he changes it and turns it
around yeah and you're like holy cow
that's that's brilliant how he does that
I try to do the caricature of because
he'll give you that
Greg Hardy's and leaders what he is he's
a leader and we need leaders on the
Cowboys because he'll say everybody's
elite it's like you said he finds a key
finds a word that he can stick on yeah
and you but you and he hits it over and
over and over later Lee hand and he
separates the word leader into two
syllables more than you'd normally say
leader and he's like a leader he's Frank
Caliendo you can learn more about Frank
and boy we learned an awful lot about
too much I'm serious on well McGinley
got me into this total mood I was like
geez this is awesome I've learned so
much in such a short time it's nothing
like being on your show see that's the
guts the comedian trying to get away
with something at the party every time I
come on the show it's going well I ruin
it the way you do that's Frank Kelly
Denis Bell upcoming live performances
audience Network he's watching right now
your
I'm gonna believe it you know pay
attention go to Franco's dance trying to
get a plug in he's got a live right let
him get it in Frank at Foxwoods in
Connecticut Boston and Wisconsin Frank
thanks for stopping I appreciate it good
always great to see you we'll come back
close up shop what we learn what's it
letting you want to take it to break
yeah what do you want to take it to
break we're gonna be a group of leaders
I'll tell you what man after the break
we're gonna wrap it up nice Christmas
like package man the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience